Although fans still have to wait almost a
year to see "The Batman" – set to hit theaters
on March 4th, 2022 — thanks to trailers
and leaks, we’re already getting a sense
of what the film will look and feel like.
One of the latest leaks features Paul Dano's
Riddler, who gets only a brief appearance
in the one trailer for "The Batman" that's
been released thus far.
The new image gives a clearer look at how
Dano's version of the Riddler will be styled
in the Matt Reeves-directed film.
If the watermark on several versions of the
photo that are currently circulating social
media is to be believed, it may have come
to us courtesy of Australian-based filmmaker
and content creator Ryan Unicomb.
The original source of the leaked photo is
unknown at this time, but it seems to be part
of a poster, calendar, or other piece of promotional
artwork that hasn't been formally released
yet.
In the freshly leaked photo — which we aren't
going to share here given that it's, well,
leaked and we’re not getting in trouble!
– Paul Dano's version of the Riddler has
his face completely covered, just like he
does in the trailer for "The Batman."
He's shown wearing glasses and a leather face
mask with eye holes, and the image as a whole
provides a much clearer idea of how he'll
present himself than the super-dark trailer
did.
The mask appears to have a flap for the Riddler's
mouth that can be covered, and doesn't seem
to be very high-tech.
Instead, it has a distinctly rough feel, as
if Dano's character sewed the whole thing
together himself.
Basically, he looks like The Machine from
the movie 8 mm — with glasses and a velcro
strip over the mouth.
It's much different than the way the Riddler
has been depicted in DC comics before.
In the comics, the Riddler has historically
been shown decked out in shades of green,
purple, and black, sporting over-the-top costumes
emblazoned with his trademark question mark
insignia.
This is the look that Jim Carrey adopted when
he played Edward Nygma, aka the Riddler, in
Tim Burton's 1995 flick "Batman Forever."
A Riddler wearing a full mask that looks totally
homemade is a far cry from what fans are used
to seeing.
After getting a glimpse of the leaked image,
fans have expressed their excitement for the
approach that director Matt Reeves appears
to be taking with "The Batman."
One fan wrote on Twitter,
"The Zodiac Killer vibes Riddler is giving
off in Matt Reeves' 'The Batman' is the exact
reason why I know he's going to blow our minds."
Another user added,
"I have no issue with the Riddler's new look
in 'The Batman' 2022.
He looks frightening and iconic in his own
unique way.
It's an intriguing reinterpretation of this
character.
We've had plenty of classic Riddler looks
on screen now so I'm fully embracing this
fresh take."
"The Batman" is set in the early days of Bruce
Wayne's time as a crime-fighter and protector
of Gotham, and Dano's Riddler is set to be
the film's main villain, a serial killer who
begins leaving clues behind at the scene of
his murders.
The element of clues makes the Zodiac Killer
a fairly natural point of comparison for Dano's
version of the Riddler.
For those unaware, the Zodiac Killer was a
serial killer who murdered seemingly random
people in northern California in the '60s
and — according to the murderer himself
— '70s.
He famously taunted the police and newspapermen
with letters and ciphers — one of which
was only deciphered in 2020.
It seems Dano's Riddler will do something
similar; in the trailer, Batman reads a cryptic
letter the Riddler left behind on a dead body.
All a part of his love of riddles, right?
For countless fans, this newly leaked photo
of the Riddler's mask only reaffirms beliefs
that Dano’s Riddler will be one for the
ages.
One user wrote on Twitter,
"Even though we have to wait until next year,
I just can't help but have the feeling that
Paul Dano is going to crush it as The Riddler
in 'The Batman.'
This could be potentially one of the best
comic book movie villains."
Another Twitter user tweeted,
"Paul Dano's Riddler is going to be one of
the greatest [comic book movie] villain performances
of all time mark my words."
Back in May 2020, Dano spoke to the Playlist,
revealing that he was excited about what "The
Batman" could be.
Joking that he couldn't say much about the
film without getting in trouble, Dano said,
"I feel really good about it.
I think Matt Reeves is the real deal.
I was really surprised by his script, which
I think is, is potentially really powerful.
[...] There's something fun there in my character
and in all the characters.
It's the kind of movie that we're just desperate
to share on the big screen in a big way.
... It will be worth [the wait].
It's going to be really cool."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about The Batman
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don’t miss a single one.